i'm interested in rules and underlying
structures and algorithms and ways of
creating pattern it's all sequences of
light that are highly subjective
you know i take inspiration from all the
systems found around the bridge you know
the movement of water the sky
clouds traffic anything that's kind of
kinetic i use as inspiration for the
pieces
we have 25 000 white led lights and they
come on a cable and they're separated by
one foot from node to node and then the
suspender cables are 30 feet apart so
there's a large gap between them what
we've had to do is run power all across
the bridge we've also had to run a big
fiber optic network so we have a 1.8
mile long cable the lights receive power
but they also need data
each light is capable of displaying 255
levels of brightness so we're sending 25
000 bytes 30 times a second
what we have now is a real-time
control system which has multiple layers
and sequences of lights i can control
brightness contrast
speed on each independent layer and then
the layers are put together and there's
different ways of combining the layers
do all kinds of mathematical operations
on it and there's a huge amount of
content and it's being dynamically
recombined so that allows for the piece
to look new you know every time someone
looks at it it makes the piece very
livable and it's not something that
keeps repeating
over two years i think people will
continue to see new things in it
you